you're doing a lot of stretching while
you're here let me just hold you i've
been in italy for five months right now
yes
nothing no there's no confined space
like italy i feel like i'm still in a
goddamn plane in this room okay the
plane makes sense yeah it just does feel
like why why are you why are you
stretching so much because i've been in
italy
you broke me
did you have a good time in italy come
on yes but we're not talking about that
yes we are [ __ ] no yeah i still got a
process i got to go to therapy no you
had a great time how much therapy do you
get
i don't know how much do you want yeah a
lot
it's good i'm a big believer in it do
you got a good one we don't talk about
it now i do have a good therapist i do
actually okay i'll send you to my
therapist promise yeah okay it's three
large men really yeah just big fat guys
i'm not allowed to go to men anymore oh
really what happened
what did you do i don't know but i have
to talk about that in the next session
okay good well let's figure that out are
you really all you can't go to a male
therapist i made this rule for myself
good that's probably good
i do have to say i do like a woman
therapist i find that i'm more relaxed
around a woman therapist when it's a guy
i'm i get kind of competitive with them
and i think well i think i figured out
my issue faster than you
i'm not going to explain my psychology
but
let's just say it's not a good idea not
a good idea we won't go there i don't
know yeah i don't know anymore well if
you do i'll take whoever you got just
give them to me now i want that
therapist no maybe i'm your therapist
right now maybe you want i'm i am very
good i'm very empathetic shut up girly
i'm very empathetic all right well
here's how i feel i feel like my
boundaries have been pummeled really
yeah that's terrible and i'm not going
to stand for it anymore well you
shouldn't and that'll be 900
okay
great
here's the sense i get of you odd aubry
i almost called you audrey but i'm going
to call you aubrey instead whatever um
whatever it's your name you can't say
whatever and roll your eyes about your
name names
hello alice whatever
aubry i think that you're very good at
defending your boundaries
i do because all you have to do
is i mean you're an intimidating person
i'm not you are i'm not
i'm not this is my this is this is a
this is no
yes you know what i'm gonna
i'm making a left turn i think we there
are certain similarities that we have um
i think we
are somewhat conflicted about our past
we have churning burbling inner psyches
and uh
we love to both uh play in the pool of
awkward is this your pitch for being my
therapist yes okay but no i think i'd be
terrific i really do think i could help
you okay fine you just say that about
everything i'd love to
what i'm hearing is let's just start a
session right now let's go let's do it
how are you aubrey i don't know i feel
broken
really what makes you feel you're broken
i don't know it just something feels
wrong like something feels wrong does it
just feel right okay
well on paper everything seems good but
okay i don't know do you mind if i'm
sorry i have a cannoli here do you mind
if i eat it while you talk
i got it on the way in and i know we're
not supposed to eat i'm literally
triggered by cannolis right now okay
i've been in sicily for four months if i
see another goddamn cannoli i swear okay
i'll just yeah
a little later do you mind if i have
some yoo-hoo i think a little yoo-hoo
here that's fine okay that's fine all
right
so why do you think you feel broken oh i
don't know no no i don't know i don't
know
oh man that's good and chocolatey oh god
so
i
really
think that can you just cross your legs
it's the wide open stance
sure i'll cross them they're very weak
so i have to actually lift one and put
it
there let's see there we go god god
these are short jean shorts
god so what do you think is making you
uptight right now he said wearing his
very short tight jean shorts
with cannoli flower all over his
kneecaps and yoo-hoo on his lips what do
you think is bothering you i don't know
just no just um
i'm just
good i'm good aubrey do you think you
could get me an audition for something i
know that you're a big deal in the
industry i just like to work in film is
that possible is this crossing some kind
of boundary no i'll do whatever you want
okay you deserve this great i deserve
this i'll just slide head shot across to
you thank you that's it i'll spend all
my time working on this thing that's a
quad split on the back that's me as a
nerd me as a cool guy me as a
construction worker and me as a guy who
make it a pizza pie
i think that went really well me too
thank you so much i helped you a lot
yeah i'm good
you're good now yeah we're good
wow
i fixed you